along my hole my name is Taylor
hole
designer I have
speaking with you all today a little bit
about myself but more importantly
something I'm very passionate about my
Hawaiian culture and how it's paved the
way for Buddhist for me to be successful
in fact
so today I'm a senior senior UI UX
designer at twitch other headquarters
over at San Francisco in my past I
worked at companies like Unity
Technologies have actually started my
career not too far from here now in Ala
Moana Boulevard in downtown Honolulu at
wall-to-wall studio
show of hands who here considers
themselves
alright ok ok so now for the rest of you
that didn't raise your hands what about
your work is what you do create alright
lots of nodding heads ok cool
I'm in the right room that's majority of
us here so because of that I'm really
excited to spend these next few days
with everybody here at JS comp
harnessing creativity I guess has been
this ongoing adventure of mine from
printing my earliest sticker slaps to
producing on the street interview shows
to working on short films and making
surfboards and making t-shirts and
producing graphics now amongst amongst
the many there's one craft that has
always had my heart web design a web web
design I mean if you could call this
that so like many of you I started
building websites at a very early age I
was 14 at the time when I published this
work of art to the World Wide Web
it was a mix of boilerplate PHP
templates FTP applications that I just
kind of learned as I went and Photoshop
tutorials on pirated software it was
kind of like all just duct-taped
together barely holding on
now fast-forward 15 years I work on
designing products that touch millions
today twitch is a popular live streaming
platform most well-known for gaming and
eSports but it also has growing
communities within our IRL or in
real-life categories like travel art and
exercise it's the kind of place to work
where culture fit means identifying
memes it's amazing so now I decided now
I design products what does that
actually mean so you think this design
software like Big Ma I come up with
interfaces and user flows for the things
that we ship to our users a couple
examples include on the left the email
verification step during new user
onboarding and dead-center is our new
channel profile page this is kind of
like cutting-edge stuff I think we ran
it to an experiment group so far so it's
technically public
also dip into my roots as a developer
using internal built systems like our in
a house divided prototype tool I built
in browser prototypes using knowing
react and typescript has allowed me to
be just dangerous enough the biggest
benefit is deeply understanding how our
primitives work together in a kind of a
production like environment these
prototypes are used as proof of concepts
as well as tools for user testing but
I'll okay just like flexing on my
engineers every now and then
uh I'm also the designer responsible for
the great round if occasion of user
avatars but something we did some eight
months ago you'd expect this that I've
been a fairly straightforward process
just update the default border-radius
unum that's on our avatar component but
half of design is building support for
your ideas so and and that's which don't
expect don't expect things to be that
easy
now I've often wondered what has helped
inspire my creativity in these last 15
years a lot of life and a lot of
learnings have happened how did I end up
working in such a rapidly growing
industry now I think it has a lot to do
with very fortunate timing I grew up in
the Internet age I had a computer at
home but above all there was one thing
that has continued to inspire me
creatively
do believe being born and raised with
the values and hard knocks of a Hawaiian
culture that any impact I've been able
to achieve has been rooted in my
upbringing
I'd like to share with you all today is
Cola here repeat after me :
so you could define Cola Hijaz
mischievious rascal rogue or to be a
prankster
one thing I know for sure Hawaiians are
hollow here ah the invent of the flip
camera phone
amazing
it's so cool oh hey it's in the Kona our
metaphor in our music it's in the
stories retold in our history it's in
our nature a lot of growing up was about
having fun and going against the grain
we'd always follow up talking story
about our miss house either at each
other's houses or at the lunch table
we'd always have a laugh at whose antics
stop the rest
this one is allegedly me I say allegedly
because you know statutes of limitations
and stuff I apologize if some time back
in 2009 you were randomly missing a
rubbish can cover
now in hindsight maybe it was an
interest in taking risks it was all
about what stories would stick we're all
excited about pushing the boundaries and
seeing what we could get away with
growing up Kahlua has taught me about
being calculated when taking risks what
better way to grow comfortable with
risks then throwing rationale at it
right nowadays the consequences can take
the business down so for that reason
I've come up with the framework on how
to approach this
so first set out what you're going to do
this is the fun part decide what you're
going to try at work this is driven by
team goals and things that impact their
users in my former life this was
probably driven by peer pressure and a
lack of self-awareness
next step is the careful balance of risk
and reward this is the exact part that
we skipped when we were younger so you
know apply to tech with a B with an a/b
testing framework set up you can
actually mitigate risk by sending a
limited set of users to a specific
variant
now given you've thought about it adjust
your approach or just go for it
now assuming you did it learn adjust and
depending on the type of project try
again
one of my first projects at twitch was
supporting the marathon team the
engineering team would take hard drives
of episodes and stream them back-to-back
for days on end using tools like ffmpeg
we would also build out unique
experience for these channel pages
marathon hit home for a lot of us the
marathon was unique because it added a
fundraising component for local PBS
stations the marathon happened to add a
very critical time in 2017 of public
broadcasting funding was under threat by
the new acting president I won't mention
names we wanted to see if we could for
lack of better word manufacture delight
for our users he had an ongoing
hypothesis that getting users to meme in
Chad would lead them to coming back who
wants to miss the next inside joke we
did this by applying a black and white
CSS filter to the entire interface
during the black-and-white episodes that
aired during the 1960s needless to say
we learned a ton from this experiment
we indeed did get a negative feedback
for one chat complain from telling
others you know they did some like
rationale calculation for how many eight
seasons were left how long they had to
wait until the black and white would go
away or they just like stayed up
complain because that's what chat does
then we started seeing interestingly
YouTube tutorials start popping up for
how to actually open inspector and
disable our CSS
you
I had to hear I had to clear out
co-workers that weren't so amused by our
active Jess
but then again we also got positive
feedback that did what that does and it
means in all of its glory there were
jokes about black and white TV and
invention of color not only that but our
fundraiser was largely successful we
raised over 42,000 dollars for local PBS
on top of that we got really good
feedback internally I had a director
reach out excited about our team being
bold in finding ways that the later used
making an impact on the world is just
going to take a little below
that's my boy
okay so the next concept that I'd like
to share with you all is rooted in Aloha
repeat after me Aloha mine
in our Aloha
very good so you could define Aloha as
hello or goodbye I'm sure when you
walked in the airport you heard all
kinds shock about is like oh no Hahn's
oh but it also means love affection
compassion mercy sympathy kindness
sentiment in Greece
here's a quote from probably the most
renown ambassador of Aloha Duke
Kahanamoku here he talks about his
perception of Aloha
but distill it down Aloha is about love
understanding making friends and taking
care of one another
he leaves us with the call to action to
meet and leave people with Aloha
everywhere you go
is a directional marker from my vocab
things out there so Aloha and off go
together means putting good vibes out
into the world be generous with your
time when people reach out for he'll be
happy to me a part of a part of it is
remembering where you were a year ago
say five years ago think back to when
you just got started and be friendly
smile make eye contacts day what's up to
the guy that you see in the hallway all
the time
contrast the suffix my me reverses the
direction if done right opportunities
will start to conquer where he opens to
them that's the people you meet by
default then calibrate by learning to
tell the bad from the good have an error
of receptiveness
in to be an antenna for good things and
good things will come
so for all my visual thinkers first you
must carry Aloha with you everywhere you
go this is the exact concept of Aloha oh
I don't like putting it out into the
world
surely people will reciprocate its kind
of the idea of Aloha money you'll end up
receiving it
and you'll find that aloha propagates
aloha impact what's around you and
what's around you will impact you that's
just how it works
in San Francisco its this hustle and
bustle being surrounded by hundreds of
thousands of people kind of all packed
in this 40-something square miles it's
easy to forget the importance of being
kind generous and thoughtful but by
carrying aloha you stand out and it has
even more of an impact on people
how you would order one of these and
help by email
what would you call it
Oh bra plate lunch that's my dog with
someone dog plate lunch mixed plate is
another word too so here is one of the
more famous examples of a mixed plate
over at rainbows drive-in it's about ten
minutes from here right off Kalakaua
Avenue we can go check them out later
tap me on the shoulder we go I get my
4runner considered the variation of food
here from mahi-mahi - chicken - Terry
beef potato salad all over a bed of rice
continue it on your plans that afternoon
gravy all over all together this mix is
heavenly
a plate lunch is a artist sorry a mixed
plate is a plate lunch with several
types of main or entree servings put on
the same plate it's also how you
describe someone with multiple ethnic
backgrounds
California so a lot of us here have rich
mixed Heritage's a quarter of us here
are mixed essentially in one way or
another
researchers at Pew Research Center
actually found that Hawaii has the most
mixed people in the United States
one em a mixed plate
Native Hawaiian Chinese Japanese
Portuguese Jeremy and all those squashes
what we call it that's kind of like all
of the best foods all in one that's me
so I tend to also follow this path in my
professional life UX designer UI
developer motion graphics graphic design
data visit visualization it it tends to
lead to a lot of inner turmoil but I
digress
so this diversity range is a strength
it's kind of like having more tools in
the tool belt so to say and a recent
piece published in The New York Times
the title says it all want to be less
racist move to Hawaii the articles point
expands beyond race
it talks about how navigating multiple
worlds enhances mental flexibility
of mental flexibility is what we call a
cognitive bias it's known as functional
fixedness it's the inability to think
outside of the box it's essentially the
expectation that people have when they
approach new problems with old solutions
expecting different results
even those arguing about texts have the
Paramount success as they say what got
you here won't get you there
Timur leading one remember the things
that make you you it takes every one of
us all aspects of us to create to
produce creative solutions
at a mackerel or team level it's all
about finding you're surrounding
yourself with people who think
differently than yourself during Hawaii
we're constantly faced by different
thinking people from your friends to
your neighbors to your classmates their
distant family members whatever and my
cousins auntie's brothers husband's
husband's boyfriend
oh we're constantly face to face with a
diverse population context switching
becomes natural
not about hiring diversity to meet quota
hiring goes with novel problem-solving
will improve your ability to innovate
and because we don't have the ability
because we don't have the brilliant
minds of marginalized people
contributing we need to start welcoming
the man-boy
concept I'd like to share is more
clucking repeat after me both bye
lokahi as unity agreement or harmony
Mulcahy in the canoe
in canoes in my early teens to my
twenties we were super competitive
we were absolutely obsessed
in the troop in the canoe everyone
serves a role there's no dead weight in
the boat once it's the pace and other
watches closely to keep the canoe in
sync
a couple stay true and just blast the
next works as utility man and the last
controls the direction of the boat just
like in
when applying lokahi at work consider
the Triforce
I'm
really good Olivia it's a mix of experts
in multiple disciplines at work it's the
mix of product engineering and design
just like in the canoe we all rely on
on each other for what we bring to
the team for example design brings
visual thinking and a passion for the
user experience engineering brings
systems thinking and a deep
understanding of the feasibility of
building a thing and product brings
coordination and an understanding of
product liability
to dependent dynamics between each of us
it's critical that we trust each other
and gift me back when it's needed the
improvement of one of us strengthens the
whole system
in the end when we work together magic
is the result at work it's building
things were proud of in the canoe it was
state championships humble brag we won
three
so now it takes more than just the three
of us at work like a child a good
product takes a village consider how any
of these affirm engines dynamics can be
applied to the multitude of supporting
functions that exist on our team
you know you're my arnica wanna and that
means and so the story is told but what
I'll leave you with is now that I've
shared a bit about myself I'd love to
hear about you what's the story that you
want to tell yourself as someone that
works intact
face that you don't see too many of in
the tech crowd know the value that you
bring and lead with your uniqueness of
course you need to know your explicit
trade say flawless test-driven
JavaScript but let your personal
background shine
a position to hire look out for these
people remember that these unique
thinkers will be the key to your success
with that Mahalo Nui Aloha Aloha Aloha
you